Miley Cyrus says there will be no  catfights on the voice season 11 it's  like a total love fest the 23 year old  singer was on Tuesday night's episode of  The Tonight Show with Jimmy Fallon where  she assured fans that she and fellow new  coach Alicia Keys have nothing but love  for one another I think people when they  put girls on TV they expect this is how  we're gonna get the ratings cuz there's  gonna be drama and there's gonna be cat  fights and we couldn't be more opposite  and we just both love music hashtag girl  power Cyrus also revealed she's hopeful  one of them wins I think we have a good  chance of I hope I win but Alicia could  possibly do though she kept mum on her  relationship with Liam Hemsworth she did  show off her sparkling engagement ring  talking quite heavily with her hands we  see that bobble Miley et spoke with  Miley's bow recently where he revealed  he no longer talks about his personal  life but he did tell us this everyone's  happy I'm happy  you